welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar biomarkers of
aging presented by dr. Alex Jabbar Anka
founder and CEO and in silico medicine
my name is sorry Grameen and I will be
your moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by loggers
blabbers is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars before we begin I'd like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers consuming
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located on the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits now
without further ado please join me in
welcoming dr. Jeff Arrancar I will now
turn the presentation over to him hello
ladies and gentlemen it's a great
pleasure for me to present to you today
a via lab roots it's my first attempt at
this particular presentation style and
please forgive me if I kind of steer or
click the wrong button here I'm
presenting as the CEO and founder of a
company called in silicon medicine we
are the next gen AI company focusing on
drug discovery biomarker development and
aging research we are the Seabee inside
stop 100a I company's in 2018 we are
first in Sullivan best practices North
American actual intelligence for
aging research and drug development
company this year and we are in pretty
much every analytical report we publish
at the rate of about two research papers
a month
I pretty much more than most AAA
companies out there and we'd like to
share our work in biomarkers of aging
today even though we focus on the entire
full spectrum of pharmaceutical R&D and
try to generalize in multiple areas
multiple disease areas and also in
multiple phases of Pharma R&D so first
things first one of the most inefficient
industries on the planet is the
pharmaceutical industry and if you think
about what industry is going to be the
most disrupted by AI going forward it is
likely not going to be the
transportation industry because in
transport in in automotive you pretty
much get from point A to point B 99.999
percent of the time and I can only make
this process more efficient and reduce
the number of accidents in the
pharmaceutical industry you've got
ninety two percent failure rate usually
after the molecules have been tested in
mice so those failure rates translate
into enormous costs an enormous cost or
R&D burden for the pharmaceutical
companies and it costs more than 2.6
billion dollars to develop a drug from
preclinical to market stages so this
slides depict how the pharmaceutical R&D
looks like so this gray dots represent
the kind of number of failures per phase
so there are lots and lots of compounds
that you usually start with in the the
basic research stage progress and the
drug discovery preclinical phase and
then there are a large number there is a
large number of failures in phase 1
phase 2 phase 3
and then if you fail at the you know FDA
review or phase three it's usually very
expensive failure so the goal of our
company and I think of the entire AI for
pharma industry today is to develop
really great molecules for precise right
molecular targets delivered at the right
time to the patient at the very early
basic research stage to reduce the
failures in the various phases of R&D
and that's our core goal and to do that
you need to focus on multiple areas of
from a silikal drug discovery to make
sure that you predict everything in the
future of the pharmaceutical or in the
cycle to avoid all kinds of expensive
failures and a ton silico we offer a
very unique blend of biology chemistry
and digital medicine expertise and try
to train our models to fit the
biological hypothesis chemistry
knowledge chemistry expertise and also
looking few into the future in the
digital medicine and we have a set of
tools for that so this is how the
pharmaceutical drug discovery pipeline
looks like usually you have for a
hypothesis and knowledge discovery phase
where you identify the disease target
Association and also hypothesize about
the origin and ethnology of the disease
then you progress and identifying
specific biological targets that drive
the disease or that are causal or that
are or that are passengers in the
disease but suppressing them or
activating them might be beneficial for
the patient then for those specific
protein targets or put or sets of
targets for a specific condition you
start generating special compounds and
we are one of the big players in that
space you can do it there'd be a virtual
screening so by screening non-chemical
space and on chemical live
libraries against the protein target or
you can do what we are trying to do and
I'll really touch on that you can
generate normal compounds for a specific
target then there is a process for aadmi
tox prediction there is clinical trials
so all those phases where you actually
go into humans
then it's a good idea to personalize
your molecule for a specific patient
subpopulations so you're addressing only
those patients that are most likely to
respond to the treatment and it's very
important to collect real-world evidence
and real world insights into a system
which can also relate back into
hypothesis and assist the company or the
entire industry with new insights coming
from patient patient populations and of
course you can use AI for marketing of
the products because if you know the
patients that are likely to respond to
the treatment and the most likely to
benefit you can cater to those specific
patients through the doctors or through
the various organizations that deal with
those patients this is how our modus
operandi kind of the central dogma of
drug discovery using AI in silico looks
like so we focus primarily on
identifying protein targets within a
variety of diseases primarily using
transcriptomics proteomics and
metabolomics data coming from public and
also from our own data databases we try
to establish this disease target
Association to link the right target or
sets of targets to a specific disease
and we go on to prior art and look at
grants locations patterns clinical
trials and also many other sources to
strengthen our hypothesis for disease
target Association and once we establish
a little bit more evidence and stronger
signals for a specific protein target
then we go and generate a specific
normal molecule or set of molecules for
that protein target and we run through
running through sets of predictors
predictor of clinical trials outcomes
then we send it the Sunda molecules and
actually the structure is to our
partners that synthesize those molecules
currently we'll work with Russia aptech
it's kind of the Ferrari of synthetic
chemistry that manages to synthesize
molecules very very quickly very
precisely and also capture is a lot of
valuable data that they pass back to us
after we contact them to do so to do
that so I highly recommend that
particular partner for synthetic
chemistry and for many other preclinical
exercises so after you get those
molecules validated we are licensed or
partner on highly promising hits and
leads and take a small percentage in the
molecule when the license it to a
smaller biotech or even to Big Pharma
this is a little bit more expanded view
of what we do and again most of the
clinical trials fail because you really
missed the target in a specific disease
or select the wrong patient sub
population for it for those targets but
we of course link it to chemistry and
try to link chemistry back into biology
to assist a target ID process with with
the chemistry expertise and also work in
clinical trials outcomes predictions we
published some of those pieces in
peer-reviewed journals to help other
academics and industry partners to get
into those fields and to replicate our
work one of the hypotheses that I came
up with that in silico is that the
various diseases have their own clocks
so you really need to capture not only
need to stratify the patients into
specific patient subpopulations and
identify the right patient for the right
drug but also the various
diseases once they manifest in the set
of symptoms it's they become pretty much
irreversible so you start treating the
symptoms but it's very difficult to go
back to the root cause some of the
examples are for example scleroderma so
which starts as an autoimmune disease
and that manifests as fibrosis sclerosis
and many other symptoms and you really
need to fix those symptoms first the
manifestations of the disease or the
tissue specific level on a systemic
level before going to the root cause
you know fixing the immune system might
not be enough so you really need to also
time the intervention to the specific
disease clock and to understand that
particular disease clock we need to
understand the biology in a very
holistic manner and one of the areas
that allows you to look at biology in
very holistic manner and Letisha
specific level on a systemic level even
on the population level and
psychological level is aging research
and one of the kind of simple ways to
describe what happens with us during our
life is this slide so we were born in
this world we grow we mature we
reproduce we peak as individuals we take
care of our young and then we
continuously decline gets sick and
eventually die
so with prevention and with diet and
exercise you can shift this curve to the
right
but the real outcome and the end outcome
is pretty imminent and it's very
difficult to do something about it and
also to protect the individual from
diseases in in the later eight years so
the only way to prevent that is by
proactive intervention and by really
understand
the aging process and ways to rewind or
put the stop to some of the aging clocks
so this is kind of for also a
philosophical chart but also it might
help you think of you know the meaning
of life a little bit differently and
help us become better doctors and better
scientists I so there are multiple ways
to measure human performance during our
lives so one measure is money not worth
the results our reputation
number of kids a level of happiness how
we live so number of experiences all
kinds of skills we aggregate physical
performance how good of an athlete you
are for some time again there is a clock
that's ticking that affects that
particular feature and the score years
of life left technological advances that
we're bringing to the world love no
number of connections that we make the
resources that we accumulate or create
all kinds of power functions and there
is another score that I myself
personally optimized for and the company
is optimizing for and that term is quali
quality adjusted life years quali is a
very well known term in healthcare
economics and that's basically a year of
life lived in the optimal state of
health basically if you are to be sick
and be maybe half of your physical
performance on half of operator to half
of your optimal abilities that would be
half of the quality so to get one
quality you need to live for two years
in that particular state of physical
activity physical performance
so one quali is one quality adjusted
life here a year of life left in the
optimal physical performance so ed in
silico we are trying to maximize the
number of GWAR global qualities and it's
a very simple objective function for the
company for the individual and for our
algorithms so we
try to maximize qualities for the
individual so stretched life or in
optimal health for as long as possible
and also treat aging as a staged disease
and what a turn turned out to be our
aging research to be turned out to be a
very very good mechanism for making AI
more interpretable so when you're
training deep neural networks on
continuously due to terminal data
annotated with age and comprising a very
simple set of features we can look at
what kind of features are more important
for making a prediction of the
individual age or you know biological
age or chronological age and the
building causal graphs looking at how
those the importance of every feature
changes in time giving us some idea of
how the biology changes in time how
damage accumulates and it turned out
that AI can be a great tool for aging
research as well so it gives you a very
holistic way of looking at things
looking at biology as well focusing on
aging research and there has been many
studies done on that performed on that
it's probably the most impactful area
for increasing life expectancy for the
populations in the developed countries
and also in developing countries as well
so if we cure cancer nowadays it's going
to add just a few years to life
expectancies in developed countries if
we delay aging and that slowed down the
ages so she ate retardation we can gain
decades in a healthy productive life as
well
aging as all of us know and it's a
statistically proven fact is very
related to disease most of the diseases
are age-related we accumulate damage
over time and that damage helps
I develop all kinds of diseases and at
some point of time it breaks into
processes that are irreversible so when
you are looking at many cancers for
example or many other diseases I and
look at them in the disconnected fashion
so look at many patients with various
heterogeneous cancers you are looking at
pieces of the broken glass and trying to
piece them all together or try to find
spots where we can intervene and glue
them back together or completely
eliminate those pieces of the broken
glass to ensure that the rest of the
kind of glass can be maintained and
remain unaffected but aging research
allows you to look at some of those
processes in time and look at how this
glass accumulates damage and breaks into
disease so many data sets out there that
lack annotation biological annotation or
have a specific sets of parameters for a
specific disease usually do have age so
age is the most abundant feature out
there everybody has age not everybody
has diabetes or cancer every cancer is
different but everybody every living
creature and actually every everything
has age in this world so if we train
deep neural networks to predict age on
multiple levels and model multiple data
types gives us a very holistic view on
biology and we can then retrain those
networks on specific diseases using
process and the methodology called
transfer learning or one-shot learning
the Train on age and then you retrain on
diseases and we can also look at what
specific features are most important in
all kinds of biological processes but
primarily looking at aging and the adult
silico as a men
and we do publish consistently we have
an academic culture and this is a list
of some of our publications related to
deep learning and some of our
publications that I'm going to cover
today are specifically focused on deep
biomarkers of aging so deep neural
networks trained to predict the age of
the patient and either retrained on
diseases or used to identify biological
targets or used to develop new methods
for interpreting biological deep neural
networks trained on biological data and
one of the recent papers that we've
published in aging research reviews one
of the high-impact journals in the field
is this so it's called artificial
intelligence for aging and longevity
research research of recent advances and
perspectives and it covers quite a bit
of our aging clocks that were developed
by our group and also other groups in
the field when it touches on multiple
applications of AI for drug discovery
biomarker development and aging research
so you can use deep neural networks for
building aging clocks so I'm gonna cover
this in in this presentation but you can
use deep learning also to identify JIRA
protectors molecules that either mimic
certain biological processes for example
caloric restriction for the activity of
pharmaceutical company compounds like
repre myosin on metformin or I can look
for molecules that negate the aging
signatures in variety of tissues kill
senescence cells or target specific
aging mechanisms and that particular
paper has an overview of that can use
deep neural networks for biomarker
development including extracting
valuable biological pathways from deep
neural networks can use AI for compound
similarity scoring
cross-species analysis target indication
etc so as I've mentioned one of the ways
to apply deep learning for aging
research is to Train deep neural
networks to predict just one feature age
using multiple data types and also
coming from patients of various ages
ideally from the same patient over time
but we can also glue together multiple
data types I just by training the neural
networks to predict age and also
identify multiple biological features
that are extremely important in a
variety of biological processes from
deep neural networks trained on those
various data types and also understand
what data type is more valuable for your
particular application from those deep
neural nets trained on age we can
extract relevant biological pathways
identify targets draw causal graphs and
also use those deep neural networks for
synthesizing new data previously I that
does not exist in nature just by
shuffling this particular feature age
and I'll illustrate that so here we are
using a technique called generative
adversarial network where two deep
neural networks are competing with each
other to essentially imagine novel
objects or novel data that does not
exist in nature with specific generation
conditions that we specify upfront and
here we specify just the age of the
person so that's myself I'm 40 today
here I actually think I do look twenty
that's a computer-generated image and
here we didn't do anything with the hair
but you can see that the deep neural
network I really modified my face to
look 70 and this is just a graphic
example of what happens when we apply
generative cell networks to all kinds of
data just by manipulating one feature
age when we do it on other data types
like for example
atomic data type or blood tests or
proteomic data or epigenetic data the
deep neural network does much better
than with images because here you've got
a lot of features basically hundreds of
thousands or even millions of millions
of pixels when you're doing it with
transcriptomic data you're working with
no twenty the expression levels of
20,000 genes or you're working with
blood tests you might be working with
just tens of features that are
reconstructed using Gans
and you can very quickly check whether
the data synthesized using AI is good or
not in our case we did test this data
and many experts fail to distinguish
between synthetic data and the data
generated using our Gans that's how good
it is you can now synthesize synthetic
patients you can synthesize patients of
a variety of ages and also with a
variety of conditions you can introduce
unit ation for example I into the into
the transcriptome for example and see
how that mutation effects the
transcriptome going forward of a patient
of a different age and most importantly
synthetic date data generated using
those guns currently that's kind of up
for discussion but it doesn't seem to be
able to belong to a specific patient so
it's computer generated data synthesized
from millions and millions and millions
of feature is obtained from consented
data and we can now generate virtual
populations of human patients or animal
patients or animal models you can also
do the exactly same thing with cells on
tissue specific level or culture
specific level when you're working with
cell lines or I can even do it on a
single cell level again train the deep
neural nets to predict the state the
differentiation state of the of the
other cells or the aging senescence
state of the cell on multiple data types
and then again extract valuable pathways
argit's causal graph synthetic generate
synthetic data synthetic cell data you
can also screen for JIRA protectors so
for example when you're working with
transcriptomic profiles you can compare
the transcriptomic profiles of young
patients with the transcriptomic
profiles of old patients and look at
what features change during aging and
what features can be causal and what
features can be targeted and identify
molecules that can target those specific
features or in one of the studies we
looked at a specific range of molecules
that induce suit inserting
transcriptional response linked it to
mesh terms reduce dimensionality using
signaling pathway analysis and train the
deep neural networks to identify whether
this molecule might have an anti-aging
and prolong evety activity or not and
one of the tools we developed for
working with transcriptomic data and
also proteomic data and actually many
types of omics data types it's called i
ponder'd so this technique allows you to
group genes and the networks and look at
the differential state change of those
networks in time or between different
state states like for example normal
view and tissue afflicted by disease and
that algorithm is used ubiquitously in
academia and industry we use this tool
to go down from you know 20,000 genes to
maybe 200 300 pathway scores and train
deep neural networks on lower
dimensionality data and also this those
scores are usually much less much more
robust and much less susceptible to
variability induced by you know batch
effects or experimental conditions or
experiment or introduced conditions and
one idea we got a few
years ago in 2015 again our company
started and deep learning in 2014 and in
aging research way before that so one of
the ideas was to create a dataset of
young and old patients so basically gene
expression data annotated with age and
build aging specific signatures using
this iPhone the algorithm by comparing
all cells and the young cells and then
looking at transcriptional response
experiments like the Broad Institute's
connectivity map or links we are a very
large number of cells and cell types
were incubated with a large number of
compounds and gene expression was
measured before and after incubation
with a compound and build the kind of
compound specific response signatures in
a variety of four cell types and then
see if we can negate those aging
signatures with those compound
signatures compound and use signatures
so and when we got an idea that why
don't we identify natural compounds
targeting senescence pathways using that
particular technique then launched
combinations of this compounds as
nutraceuticals and then measure a
variety of biomarkers in real world and
evaluate the possible side effects so
people take those nutriceuticals
anyway and millions so why don't we also
try to measure the effects so published
a couple of papers on that in credible
academic journals peer-reviewed academic
journals did some experimental
validation on the cell level and then
partnered with a nutraceutical company
called life extension it caters to about
450,000 people predominantly in the
United States three catalogue and those
the users of life extension products are
usually a little bit more educated than
the general public that is taking your
sitacles
and life extension is offering annual
blood tests for for their use user base
or regular blood tests with a
partnership with LabCorp so you can
actually
take a blood test and see whether a
specific nutraceutical is working or not
it's very difficult to identify whether
it is working or not so we launched a
series of nutraceutical products
primarily comprised of the molecules
that people are taking anyway in large
quantities for anti-aging but we have
specific rationale for those molecules
to be consumed in those combinations and
we tested the some of those molecules in
vitro it takes us about four weeks to
predict 25 weeks to do safety taste
testing also in short as grass approved
and I combined in I in a specific
capsule then the the product is launched
and then we expect people to upload some
of their data in an anonymous way I
totally know anonymous
through a system called young AI and
then we can test and analyze so
currently we are collecting those data
types through a system called young AI
it's currently in beta and that system
allows you to upload your photos your
blood tests wearable data ECG and the
transcriptomic data we are adding micro
Bionic aging clock soon and then see how
a variety of interventions might affect
your predicted age and this is how the
dashboard looks like and now we're
getting into the kind of topic of the
aging clocks and aging biomarkers so
this industry has been revolutionized by
Steven Horowitz's work Steve Horvath out
of UCLA in 2013 published the first
aging clock epigenetic aging clock in
2013 and genome biology I highly
recommend looking at his paper
I respect for this work scrupulous and
the single author publication showing
that you can now use methylation data to
predict the person's age with two point
seven minutes of error so it's basically
plus minus two point seven years for
guessing your chronological age with
consistency so it's a very robust clock
there are other epigenetic aging clock
so pretty much every group developed
their own um and including ourselves by
using the various techniques including
deep learning we also publish the first
bio chemistry based clock using deep
neural nets which is about five point
five years accurate it's not as
consistent as epigenetic aging clock
there are multiple other clocks like
transcriptomic aging clock telomere
clock so it in silica we have sixteen
clocks to date developed to date on the
various data types and you can develop
those clocks using a variety of methods
so Steven Horowitz's aging clock was
developed using elastic net Hannam
squawk elastic net then our clock was
developed using deep neural networks and
you can even develop aging clocks using
linear regression when you're looking at
the length of the telomeres it's
actually one of the worst clocks out
there also in my opinion one of the
least biologically relevant so one of
the ideas of developing aging for
developing aging clocks is to train a
feed-forward deep neural net with
multiple features for example regular
results from regular blood tests as
input features into the deep neural net
basically one feature per neuron and you
can use various techniques to evaluate
the selective selection for example to
evaluate the net contribution we be
contribution to the accuracy of the
prediction predictor for every
individual element going into the deep
neural net by developing single
connected layers of neurons you've got
an input layer where you know each each
feature that is going in and you've got
weighted neurons with connected to a
single feature so after the model is
trained you can take those weights and
understand what kind of
what what what is the individual
importance for every feature can do it
using various techniques and one
important question to answer ask
yourself when looking at those
biological aging clocks and when
developing biomarkers of aging is what
does it measure so one of the very
simple biomarkers of aging is is the
person's face so you can just use
photographic markers to predict the
person's chronological age and the good
doctor would even be able to tell you
some some gases about your health status
about the patient's health status and if
the doctor who is trained on several
thousand patients or maybe sometimes
tens of thousands of patients by just
looking at them can do this it means
that the deep neural net which is
trained on millions and never forgets
can likely do it better so and we can
see that for predicting the
chronological age of the of the patient
the deep neural net can outperform a
human so for example our deep neural
networks always outperform me but when
you're training or when you are
predicting the age using epigenetic data
we actually don't know what this clock
measures and how does the damage
associate with this clock accumulates
and how does it how can we use it to
develop all kinds of interventions and
what kind of interventions should be
measured with this clock and one way to
evaluate those clocks is to compare them
against each other
so here you see a comparison done by Dan
Belski at Duke University one of the
kind of top arbitraries of biological
aging clocks and he showed that there is
very little correlation between the
various clocks even the epigenetic aging
clocks developed using
varying sets of methylation sites they
differ in in performance on the same
data set and there is huge difference
with other aging clocks like
physiological aging clocks so those
aging clocks can actually be also very
useful for evaluating the value of the
data type for measuring the effects of
your intervention and to see where your
drug or where your therapy works either
it's of microbiotic level or a
transcriptomic level transcriptomic
level or you can see a signal in the
peripheral blood so it's very simple and
cost-effective way to basically do data
economics understanding the value of the
various data types and combination value
of the variety of data types so one of
the very simple aging clocks that's so
that we developed are using very very
simple data types coming from regular
blood tests so pretty much everybody has
those features that come from either
routine screening checks or routine
procedure when visiting a GP your
general practitioner those blood tests
are cheap very common widely available
non-invasive or minimally invasive so we
just need a very simple blood test they
range from you know 10 features that you
get or even less to a panel of 50 or
more biomarkers that you're like albumin
glucose alkaline phosphatase or
something that the terms that most of us
heard in school or got interpretation
for from our GP and pretty much none of
those features can be used as a good
biomarker of Aging by itself or even in
combination so if you were to look at
just maybe ten feature is coming from
your peripheral blood test very few of
them would correlate with your
chronological age very well very
difficult to train a predictor and
usually you get very low are really low
consistency for the flows for those
features but what we did in 2015 and
published this paper in 2016 we trained
an ensemble of deep neural Nets predict
train to predict just one feature age on
a very large number of samples can um
burr of datasets comprised of just 41
parameters like young albumin glucose
alkaline phosphatase urea cholesterol
some very very simple markers in your
peripheral blood we trained the 21 deep
neural networks every single individual
deep neural network actually
outperformed pretty much every other
machine learning technique and other
statistical analysis techniques but when
you combine them in the stacking model
using elastic nut you get much higher
input you get you get an improvement in
accuracy and we predict the patient's
age reasonably well actually patients
axe is predicted very well just by one
deep neural net and with an ensemble of
the deep neural networks in 2016 again
it was a very those were very early days
of deep learning we achieved five point
five minutes for error for predicting
the person's chronological age and
anecdotally we started observing cases
where people who are predicted to be
older than their chronological age are
also also has some kind of age-related
disease and people who looked younger
than according to chronological age for
healthy individuals and most of them
came from screening experiments so there
was anecdotal evidence that people who
are predicted to be older they actually
are more sick they have some kind of
condition we also of course compared all
other machine learning techniques and
demonstrated that deep neural networks
outperform all other machine learning
techniques in statistical techniques
even though the number of features in
every in every sample is very very
little very small we still outperform
linear regression by far with deep
neural networks and we used a technique
called permutation feature importance
analysis where we construct a vector of
teachers are going the knurl not and
randomly shuffle just one so for example
randomly shuffle and the albumen value
is going as you know that and then we
look at how this random shuffling of
that feature contribute to the accuracy
of the prediction predictor itself the
entire kind of vector and using this
technique you can create a histogram of
importance of every individual feature
for making that prediction and it
basically shows that albumin is one of
the most important feature is in in each
prediction and it correlates with liver
function and with other specific changes
in in our body during aging of course
Lucas is a common criminal and it's
change in relation with other features
contributes a lot to the accuracy of the
prediction so you can derive a lot of
really interesting biological insights
from those deep neural networks when you
play with them you can also do build
prediction predictors for specific
individual aging groups for example from
twenty to thirty thirty to forty forty
to fifty and see how those importance
matrices important important histogram
change for prediction of specific age
and how those features play in specific
age groups and using this technique you
can derive causal graphs one other
application of this technique of using
deep neural networks trained on very
simple data types in a very specific
population was presented in our recent
paper in Journal of gerontology series a
rather prominent journal in in our field
there we used a very large data set many
millions of samples were profile the
normalized profiles were profiled I to
come up with a set of more or less
healthy people with an every population
Eastern Europeans Canadians and Koreans
and a deep neural network was trained or
within every population on just twenty
features
I to basically predict the patient's age
and then one feature population group
was added and we predict the population
the patient's a age using a combined
data set and there were some great
interesting QA findings there so one fun
experiment to perform is to train the
deep neural networks or on one patient
one one population group and then test
it on a completely different population
group so in this case we actually train
the deep neural network on Canadians and
got reasonably respect respectable I
mean episode error I just over five
years and then we tested this predictor
on Koreans and we got higher mean ups or
terrorism in Koreans and the Koreans in
general looked younger to the deep
neural Nets trained on Canadians and
when you test them on Eastern Europeans
they actually look older to the deep
neural net and as you'll see the mean
episode error increases so it's a very
fun way to demonstrate population
specificity of the various data types
and various biomarkers so if you were to
conduct a clinical study it's a good
idea to do an a judgment or biological
age adjustment on this level and many
possibly many other data types and that
might be because you know in Eastern
Europe the equipment is different the
quality of those lab lab tests are less
consistent and or possibly because
people are smoking and drinking so we
don't know and that's a very interesting
area of research I will also skip a few
slides just for the timing purposes here
but those slides are available for the
viewership of this webcast and and
another peculiar and interesting finding
from this study was that some of those
features that contribute most to the
accuracy of the prediction are universal
like albumin
gender oral sex glucose hemoglobin urea
and some are more population specific
like producer writes HDL cholesterol LDL
cholesterol for Eastern Europeans and
you can go into specific population
groups and and start theorizing why
those features are more important than
one population and on the other maybe
it's dietary maybe its genetic and
develop all kinds of theories using
those aging clocks so those aging clocks
are hugely valuable for understanding
the biology and also population
sensitivity of the various data types
another interesting finding from this
particular study was that people who
were we tested those predictors on an
independent data set called enhance it's
a big longitudinal data set in the US
where a variety of biomarkers ISM or
measured longitudinally and you actually
have links to some outcomes so you can
see how many people with certain markers
died and what was the cause of death so
we tested our predictors on an has data
set and got some really peculiar and
interesting results so people who are
predicted to be five years or older than
their chronological age by using the
predictor on average had much higher
hazard ratio than people who are pretty
much in line with a chronological age
and people who are predicted to be five
years or or more younger than their
chronological age they have much higher
much lower kind of all-cause mortality
rate than people who were predicted to
be within their age and chronological
age so that's a very interesting finding
and you can use it for all kinds of
purposes to build better actuarial
models or find ways to prevent all kinds
of negative if events and possibly
reduce all cause mortality or specific
cause mortality using those using those
clocks and the young hematological
might not be the best clocks to do this
we think that transcriptomic clocks are
much better and proteomics blocks are
the best but of course if you combine
those multiple data types you get even
more valuable data sets so again will
help us with data economics work another
interesting study that we recently
concluded and published was predictors
of age using transcriptomic data coming
from muscle tissue of the patients to
study the process called sarcopenia age
associated muscle wasting and we
generated and assembled a very large
data set of muscle tissue transcriptomes
from patients from 19 to 89 years old
and build a variety of predictors of
chronological age using those those data
sets are using a variety of techniques
like support vector machine like elastic
nut random forests and of course deep
neural networks using an equal deep
tissue selection we also trained on
signalling pathways to understand and
get some biological interpretation of of
those predictors and then we use a buoy
use the boil account to kind of come up
with the most important targets and most
important features from all of those
machine learning techniques to come up
with the final ranks and possibly
identifying some targets that are
implicated in that condition
so again deep neural networks pretty
much all performed every other method
and we got two pretty respectable min
episode errors with reasonably good
consistency we also used a variety of
feature importance analysis techniques
and here we used the official selection
techniques to identify the relative
importance of every every feature that
were feeding into the deep neural net
and using a variety of machine learning
techniques we ranked the various genes
by their importance for predicting the
chronological age of the patient and you
can see that various machine learning
techniques give you very very different
scores for for the genes that you're
feeding into them and for example skep 2
would not have been prioritized by deep
neural nets but it's prioritized by
random forests elastic net and it's
basically within the top 10 or using
various SVM techniques but if you do the
boilie count that ranks number one and
most of the kind of most important genes
are appear in the top 100 of using
pretty much every technique and we also
showed that some of those genes that are
implicated in muscle wasting using this
technique also are targetable so there
druggable and some of the genes some of
the possible targets like for example
the CA 4 is implicated and muscle muscle
wasting also indirectly so it's
developed for the molecule that is
targeting this particular target protein
was developed for a set of other
conditions but anecdotally and a
literature it looks like people are
using it and implicating it in all kinds
of myopathies and myotonia is so it's
indirectly
and anecdotally associated with muscle
wasting already so it's a we think that
this research area is very promising and
we encourage people to go into this area
and also collaborate with us another
interesting technique as I've mentioned
in the very beginning of my talk is
generative the cell networks so Gans can
be used for a variety of applications on
healthcare so again generating synthetic
data but also generating normal
chemistry and usually it's a very good
technique to employ and master because
if you want to validate some of those
targets that you come up with using you
know aging box or disease specific aging
this specific box or
bio-markers I you want to very quickly
synthesize the molecules that hit those
specific targets and not the others and
test those molecules in a biological
system to do basically target validation
so to do that we set on a journey in
2015-2016 using all kinds of theoretical
approaches to generate useful molecules
using deep neural networks using yawns
and spent basically two years and theory
publishing a variety of of publications
so one was the cornucopia of meaningful
leads possibly the likely the first
peer-reviewed paper in that field and
then followed with a series of other
publications and then in 2017 in mid
2017 we decided to start synthesizing
those molecules that we come up with the
theory that have those properties that
we want those molecules to have from the
very beginning of the experiment I want
to synthesize those molecules with those
properties and test them so we did it
with Russia eptak in in China and our
first experiments resulted in failure so
young in molecules is not as easy to
generate very meaningful results and
quickly validate so when you're doing it
with pictures you can very quickly
validate with your own sensory organs
the molecules you need to synthesize and
test and sometimes the essay is wrong or
your molecules is bad and sometimes you
just don't know what happened so our
first experiment didn't result in in a
success then we had several iterations
of this process and generated a lot of
really cool proprietary data that we
incorporated back into the generators
and around March 2018 we had a mild
success so most of the generation
conditions that we've embedded in the
molecule were met experimentally and we
used pretty trivial targets very well
known targets like jak kinase
cgf RBF kindnesses as targets for the
molecules that were generating using AI
and we developed three respectable
molecules that inhibited jak1 and not
Jake - even though those targets are
very similar and jak3 and not Jack Jack
- and the show that we can now create
very selective inhibitor is for those
first kindness targets but also those
inhibitors carry many other properties
that we want them to have like
solubility by availability log PSP
august w blood-brain barrier and
basically up to 33 properties from
scratch and we developed some really
cool BRF in EGFR inhibitors the
basically molecule targets both both
proteins and we can inhibit VF at pika
molar concentration and at the same time
EGFR at sorry sorry the other way around
so EGFR at the molar concentration BRF
at single-digit non a molar
concentration so that those are very
promising results and this molecule
doesn't seem to inhibit many other
kinase is and this is how we validated
so we create the molecules or we train
Gans to generate molecules with specific
set of properties so in this case you
want activity against specific kinases
you sample from the latest space or
space to see what kind of molecular
structures are most likely to inhibit
you know jak 1 J 2 J 3 or specific
kinases then you synthesize those
molecules and test and in our keys
generation conditions were met in more
than 70% of the cases and we identified
very selectively Jaquan g3 inhibitors
and published a variety of this of these
experiments and also this models so one
of the really good papers to take a look
at is the entangled conditional
adversarial autoencoder for the no drug
discovery
it implements the new kind of
disentanglement technique and the
manifold learning in the autumn quarter
at this Ariel Atom quarter and here we
use smiles a representation of the
molecular structure so a string based
representational molecular structure I
and most of the groups I can replicate
this experiment but most interesting
factoid about this particular paper is
that we actually synthesized the normal
jig three inhibitor and tested it I in
in an enzymatic assay and also in
biological assay and we demonstrated
that it I can inhibit jak 3 at a pretty
much single-digit micro molar
concentration so it's not great but not
bad either but it inhibits jak 2 at the
millimolar concentration which is
basically significantly larger than than
project 3 and it doesn't seem to hit
other kind is strongly so it might be a
very very useful molecule to test and
now we're doing this for many many
targets that we've identified using
aging research and specific specific
disease research and we are licensing
those molecules to a variety of smaller
biotechnology companies and also to a
large pharmaceutical company and take
participation in in the future of this
molecule so we pretty much get paid only
if it's successful but we also do it a
lot for academic purposes I here is my
contact information you can reach us if
you're if you have any questions from
the economic standpoint or from
commercial standpoint we are global we
have R&D resources and nine countries
physical offices and four countries and
next year in 2019 we're moving into
China in a very big way to work with the
local partners there and to kickstart
the pharmaceutical in the
three using AI so we're very
collaboratively massively massively
collaborative currently we take one or
primarily only with very interesting
projects amber if you're interested in
learning more please just go to PubMed
and enter in silico plus medicine
thank you very much for your attention
today thank you dr. Gibran Cox for that
informative presentation I would like to
also thank moderates for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that this
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through May 2019 and as a final
reminder any questions submitted will be
followed up via email by our speaker
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we'll see you next time goodbye